あの本当に乗れるかどうか
あなたは大丈夫か?って言ったらどうぞって貸してくれるってことですね
うちのお袋がうまい乗れるなんて聞いたこともない
ちょっと孵化したんじゃないですかね
でもこの間おっしゃってた
なんか調子に乗って
今回ね、初日にお客さんで
先生のお友達だった
昔、小学生の頃軽井沢に来て
そしたらすっごく素敵なお姉様が
ローマに乗ってるのを見て
かっこよくて憧れたのよって
あ、柳屋さんのお母さんが言ってた通りだったり
駅前で馬借りて歩いて行ってたっていう
そこ軽井沢でね、一人でこう出してくれたんですよね
外に
私も自宅のお庭まで行って
両親を呼んで
今日はこれなのよって
やっぱりそうなんだ
憧れのお姉様がいたのよって
3日前聞いたばんかって
奥さんは脱がれるんですよ馬は?
いやちょっと乗ってたんですけど
落馬して、怪我してやめたって
花火が上がっちゃってね
それで馬がバーンと跳ねちゃったって
それはちょっと怖いですね
前足が顎にあたって
顎がちょっときれいって
歯が縦にさせて
えぇー
ほんまにそういう話をするって
ほら
怖がってもらうから
怖がっちゃう
でもあの高さって結構
危ないですよね
落ちたら
うん、危ないですよね
軽くポンと落ちればよかったんですけど
落ちたくなくって
下が抜かるんでて
濡れるのが嫌で
しがみついてたから
前の方にブルブルって
毛を蹴られた
落ちるときはパッと落ちた方がね
実はいいですね
あんまり怪我しい
でも本当はね
落ちたらすぐ乗れって言うんですよね
昔の人はもう厳しかったですね
もう厳しくて
私も落ちたとき
ここから血が出てるので
乗れって言うんですよね
もちろんそんなに
お気がなさってたら
乗れって
あの水で濡れて
ドロドロなのに乗れって言うから
それは馬の教えなんです
落とせば終わると思う
でもそれはやっぱり先生の方が悪いよね
そんな方をこうね
乗せて出したなんていうのはいけないですよね
落ちるとちょっと気持ちがへこみますね
それまで調子よく乗っててもね
アメリカはどうなんですか?
乗るところはたくさんありそう
ねえそうですよね
力は覚えている?
力はアメリカにいたとき
えっと
力は覚えている?
力はアメリカにいたとき
えっと